Supermarkets.
It’s hard to avoid these modern temples
of convenience and consumerism.
And like the fictitious temples from adventure
stories, they’re filled with pitfalls and
booby traps designed to make you spend more
than you planned.
As any good treasure-hunter will tell you,
you can never let your guard down.
Satipo: “There is nothing to fear here!’
Indy: “That’s what scares me.”
But with a little preparation and discipline,
you can safely swing past every metaphorical
snakepit, rolling boulder and... alien spaceship?
Let’s pretend that one didn’t happen.
Okay.
[MUSIC]
From the moment you walk through the front
doors, your senses are getting played.
Bright, colorful flowers, the smell of fresh-baked
bread, soft, comfortable music.
All these things are designed to put you in
a relaxed, suggestive state of mind so that
you’ll take your time and be more open-minded
about what you came to buy.
If you’re like most people, you probably
start in the produce section, and that’s
no accident.
Stores have found that when people stock their
cart with healthy things early on, they’re
more likely to reward themselves with junk
food later.
It may be tempting to grab some of those pre-chopped
fruits and vegetables, but take a second to
compare the price by weight.
You could be paying 2 -300% to not have to wield the knife yourself.
Plus they often have a shorter shelf-life,
and you’re creating more packaging waste.
That’s why I chop my own vegetables FIVE
days a week.
Oh, and by the way, that mist that makes everything
seem fresh and crisp?
It’s pretty much just there for show.
Constantly spraying water on produce can increase
the health risks of bacteria and make certain
fruits and veggies rot faster.
It also makes the leafy greens weigh just
a bit more at checkout, so make sure to shake
‘em out before you bag ‘em.
As you walk the aisles, remember to look up
and down, not just side-to-side.
Stores put their most expensive items at eye-level,
hoping you won’t notice the cheaper alternatives
above and below.
And yes, that applies to kid’s stuff, too.
Excuse me, would you like to try a free sample?
Uh… sure, I guess.
Free samples are more about your emotions
than your tastebuds.
They create a feeling of personal obligation,
like you’re already in too deep to back
out.
So if you’re gonna partake, be prepared
to make a clean break and move on.
You’re just gonna walk away?
After everything we’ve been through?!
Supermarkets don’t just want you to buy
expensive stuff.
They want you to buy more stuff in general.
Take this so-called “bargain.”
Most people assume they have to purchase all
ten to get some perceived discount, but if
you read the fine print, you’ll usually
find that the unit price is the same no matter
how many you buy.
It’s also why shopping carts have been getting
bigger over the years.
Marketing tests showed that shoppers spent
up to 40% more with a double-sized cart!
Those supersize carts also make it difficult
to do a U-turn in a narrow aisle so you’re
more likely to take the long way around.
A longer path means more temptations, which
is why stores will periodically rearrange
the merchandise to keep even experienced shoppers
searching.
Some people think that’s why essentials
like milk and eggs are always at the back
at the store, but store managers insist on
a more innocent reason: by law these items
can’t be unrefrigerated for very long, and
since the delivery trucks unload at the back,
it makes sense to put the fridges there.
I guess making shoppers walk through the whole
store is just a “happy accident.”
Once you’ve finally found everything you
need, there’s one more trial to overcome:
the checkstand.
This is where stores traditionally keep impulse
purchases like candy, magazines and gum because
they know that by now you’re experiencing
what psychologists call “decision fatigue.”
We get tired of being sensible and weighing
costs and benefits.
It wears us down and makes us more open to
suggestion.
So it’s best to not even look at that stuff.
“Don't look at it. Shut your eyes, Marion! Don't look at it, no matter what happens!"
These strategies have been refined over decades
to make shoppers spend more than they have
to and buy more than they need.
Unfortunately, people who buy more tend to
consume more and waste more.
It’s kind of a lose/lose/lose situation.
But shopping for groceries and cooking at
home is still cheaper and healthier than eating
out all the time--which is a major reason
why Millennials are having trouble saving
money.
So by all means: go to the supermarket…
just be prepared!
First off, and most importantly, make a list even if you have to write on a napkin in the parking lot. Don't go through those doors without it.
The fewer choices you have to make in the
store means less temptation and less fatigue.
If your store has them, use smaller carts
to discourage overbuying.
Although those handbaskets may not be a good
idea.
Studies found that the physical act of lifting
and carrying handbaskets made shoppers feel
like they deserved junk-food rewards.
The brain’s a funny thing, isn’t it?
Bring headphones and listen to upbeat music.
It will keep you fast and focused.
And never go to the grocery store hungry.
That’s just asking your reptile brain to
take the driver’s seat.
And if you still have trouble sticking to
the plan, leave your credit cards at home
and bring only what you want to spend in cash.
Julia and I have been doing that for years
and it keeps temptation in check.
Remember, these stores aren’t evil organizations
getting away with highway robbery.
In fact, as an industry, supermarkets have
one of the lowest profit margins in the U.S.,
so they rely on these mind-games just to stay
in the black.
But you have a right to defend yourself, and
the best defense is understanding how your
own brain works.
And that’s our two cents!